ich hab es gerade gesagt die die Uhren
sind gerade umgesprungen historisches
Datum der 9 November hat gerade begonnen
m
reichsprogromncht und viele noch eine
ganze Reihe ander andere Daten genau
aber speziell darüber würde ich gerne
mal mit ihnen sprechen sie waren damals
6 Jahre alt ja ich habe das nicht
wahrgenommen aber später in der Nazizeit
habe ich doch gemerkt die jüdischen
Mitbürger aus dem Haus in der Umgebung
verschwanden und me ja und meine Eltern
haben gesagt da passiert
Schreckliches und ich habe jetzt äh
entdeckt einen Ausspruch von Heus der
1952 das Lager bergenbsen besucht hat
und einfach gesagt hat Heus
Bundespresident einfach gesagt hat wir
haben davon gewusst die progomnacht
haben wir erlebt aber was dann passiert
ist wir haben davon gewusst sie sagten
gerade ihre Mutter oder wer hat das
gesagt da passiert schreckliches ja
meine meine Mutter me meine ganze
Umgebung ich habe gefragt wo sind den
meine jüdischen Freunde
Jam und äh das war das das war ich meine
hitler hat doch alles gesagt er hat
gesagt in meinen Kampf er wird die juten
ausrotten und die Menschen haben ihn
19 30 überwältigend gewählt und ich habe
die älteren Leute nach dem Krieg gefragt
hab warum habt ihr ihn denn geäht wir
haben protestiert der sag ich
protestiert wenn wir das gewusst hätten
was der Mann anrichten diesen
Weltenbrand diesen Holocaust hätten wir
das doch nie gemacht und das sollten wir
uns heute beherzigen wir haben keinen
neuen Hitler aber die Leute die jetzt
glauben sie könnten bei systemverächtern
andocken weil sie protestieren müssen
sich überlegen was sie anrichten ich
meine es ist ein sehr interessanter
Hinweis haben wir schon mal drüber
gesprochen Uwe witock glaube ich Februar
33 gibt ein tolles Buch zu dem Thema die
Nazis haben einen Monat gebraucht um
dieses Land so zu verändern dass sie
faktisch nicht mehr von der Macht
wegzukriegen waren ein Monat so schnell
ging das und das Argument dass man heute
gelegentlich hört wenn wenn wir mal die
die Analogien die Parallelen zu heute
uns anschauen Herr Baum und ich merke
dass sie da was treibt und deswegen
veröffentlichen sie Moment unglaublich
viel äh und man hat das Gefühl sie sind
in wirklicher Sorge sie sagen sogar mir
macht das Angst ja jemand wie sie der so
viel erlebt hat der an der Hand Seer
Mutter aus dem brennenden Dresden
geflohen ist der sagt mir macht das
heute Angst da hört man natürlich hin
und ich ich weiß dass damals eines der
Argumente war das beschreibt wistock
auch wenn die Nazis wenn die wenn der
Hitler wenn der da man der Macht ist
dann wird sich das entzaubern dann wer
wir ganz schnell merken die können das
nicht und dann werden die ganz schnell
in der harten politischen Wirklichkeit
ankommen und das Argument ist natürlich
falsch und das ist ein Argument D man
heute auch immer wieder hört lass die
lass die mal probieren lass die mal
Landtagswahlen gewinnen diese AFD und
dann werden die Sie schnell zau genauo
ist es und deshalb bin ich so
erschrocken wissen Sie es ist eine
schleichender Prozess nicht nur in den
wahlergebnisen der AFD es ist eine
Strömung hin zu System Verächtern ich
ich sage jetzt sogar Herr LANs die
Bindungswirkung das Grundgesetz lässt
nach auch durch diejenigen die einfach
gleichgültig weitermachen und nicht
kämpfen für diese Verfassung und durch
die durch die eine Gefahr die ich völlig
unterschätzt habe die Migranten ein Teil
der Migranten ist im Grundgesetz nicht
angekommen ja haben ein Teil den Hass
auf Israel mitgebracht ja aber wie und
dann gibt es die systemverchter die
freiheitsverchter und eines habe ich mir
vorgenommen als ich anfing Politik zu
machen ich war nicht sicher ob das
gelingen würde mit der Demokratie das
darf nicht mehr passieren das heißt die
Deutschen haben einen besondere
Verpflichtung sich von Antisemitismus
Rassismus fernzuhalten als einziges Volk
auf der Welt was die Belgier und die
Franzosen machen das das beonruhigt mich
auch aber ich lebe hier mit dieser
Tradition und wir haben eine
Erinnerungskultur aufgebaut wir haben
uns aktiv erinnert an das und das hat
diese Demokratie stark gemacht und das
darf nicht verloren gehen die Frage ist
ist es vielleicht zum Teil schon
verloren gegangen wie sie gerade
andeuten oder anders gefragt was geht
Ihnen durch den Kopf wenn sie mitkriegen
wie jüdisches Leben gerade geschützt
wird in diesem Land wie Synagogen
beschützt werden müssen schon seit
vielen Jahren wie z.B Zeitungen wie die
jüdische allgemeine die Bitte kriegen
stellt uns bitte die Zeitung so zu dass
man nicht erkennen kann dass hier
Menschen jüdischen Glaubens Beispiel
Weise wohnen dass man die Kipper unter
einem Baseball cppy trägt beispielsweise
damit man bloß nicht sieht was dieser
Mensch darunter eigentlich glaubt und
dass er Jude ist was geht ihn dann durch
den Kopf wenn sie das Hören bin zutiefst
erschrocken also ich habe nach dem Krieg
gab es eine schendung der Kölner
Synagoge
eine das hat eine ein eine ein Aufruhr
gegeben öffentlich wir haben wir haben
darüber diskutiert und jetzt gibt es
unzählige antisemitische Gewalt
antisemitische Signale ich meine man man
kann natürlich Herr Netanyahu und seine
Politik kritisieren ja der ist ein der
ist ein Unglück für dieses Land man kann
sagen die Palästinenser haben bestimmte
berechtigte Wünsche aber niemals
Antisemitismus und das das ist in dieser
Dimension Herr Lanz wie ichelst erlebe
habe ich es noch nie so erlebt es mag
schlafen irgendwo gewesen sein aber wir
haben es nicht so wahrgenommen sie haben
mit Recht gesagt ist ja schon eine
merkwürdige Situation dass vor jeder
Synagoge Polizeiwagen stehen muss ja
wann wann hat das eigentlich begonnen
ich mE ich habe es gerade erwähnt sie
waren Innenminister 78 bis 82 wann hat
das begonnen wie war das zu ihrer Zeit
seit wann muss eine Synagoge in
Deutschland so geschützt werden wie es
im Moment der Fall ist ich glaube es gab
ruhigere Zeiten ich also es ist äh äh es
gab ja dann eine Welle nicht auch äh in
den letzten Jahren ging das ja schon los
nicht diese Anschlag in Halle und so
weiter
und eine geheime Sympathie übrigens sagt
der heidmeer ein ein sehr guter
Analytiker der unserer Situation ein
Teil des Bürgertums ist verrot eine
Minderheit das heißt sie nimmt
Andersdenkende Minderheiten schwache
schutzbedürftige nicht mehr
war noch mal zu ihrer Zeit her Baum wie
war das da wir kennen noch den den den
Schlachtruf ne unter den Talaren der
Muff von 1000 Jahren und so we übrigens
übrigens auch am 9 November hier in
Hamburg richtig später ja ja ja also das
heißt wie war das zu ihrer Zeit das
Antisemitismus woher kam der und wie hat
der sich manifestiert also wir hatten
eine starke Fixierung auf die Gefahr von
links die war auch berechtigt da gab es
die Sowjetunion die hat uns bedroht da
gab es die DDR da gab es also wir waren
fixiert auf die Gefahr von links also
als meine Mutter ein Haus suchte in Köln
wo sie bauen konnen haben sie gesagt
Frau warum bleiben sie linksreinisch
verstehen sie rechtsreinisch war
gefährdet ja weil ja durch russische
Truppen eines Tages nicht also äh wir
wir haben äh und das wir waren fixiert
auf den Link auf die Bedrohung von links
und haben nicht wahrgenommen das ist z.B
ein jüdisches erzbar
äh in Bayern ermordet worden ist dass es
ein
Oktoberfestattentat von einem rechten
Extremisten gegeben hat mit den meisten
Toten in der Republik meisten Toten in
durch einen einen solchen Anschlag das
heißt der
Rechtsextremismus wurde war nicht im
Bewusstsein ob er so antim ich kann mich
nicht erinnern dass er so antisemitisch
war wer Sportgruppe Hoffmann wer
Sportgruppe Hoffmann zu ihrer Zeit ja
habe ich verboten und die Bayern W wer
wer waren diese Leute das war eine eine
Truppe die Übung gemacht hat und
eben
mit undemokratischen Mitteln an an die
Stabilität dieses Staates heran würde
man heute sagen
Reichsbürger ja würde man in diese
Richtung wir haben wir haben ich wir
haben sie verboten weil sie die eben wir
absolut verfassungswidrige Aktivitäten
entfaltet hat und zwar mit
Waffen wurden ja jetzt auch beschlagnabt
in dem Zusammenhang trotzdem noch mal
die Frage Antisemitismus der der Hass
auf Juden der Hass auch auf Juden und
und Kinder jüdischen Glaubens in
deutschen klassenz ich meine wir haben
auch in dieser Sendung so häufig in den
vergangenen Jahren darüber gesprochen
wir haben die Klage gehört und auch
darüber gesprochen wie gefäh es
mittlerweile ist mit einer Kipper
beispielsweise durch Neuköln zu gehen
das wurde hier immer wieder berichtet
aber es wurde irgendwie nicht gehört und
jetzt ist plötzlich das große
erschrecken da wir haben da ein Problem
ja also es ist offenbar wird jetzt
vieles vermischt nicht mal die Politik
von Israel
kritikwürdig in in mancher Hinsicht der
beste den es gegeben hat war Rabin des
ermordet worden und dann kam der
unselige netanyaho mit seiner rechten
Truppe jetzt nicht war mus muss ich mal
vorstellen der hat diese diese Koalition
gezimmert weil er einer Bestrafung
entgehen will er hat
das sein persönliches Schicksal an die
Zukunft des Landes sozusagen gebunden es
schrecklich gib viele Israelis die sagen
sein Schicksal hängt auch an diesem
Krieg deswegen hat dieser Mann kein
Interesse sagen Leute die die so
argumentieren dass dieser Krieg so
schnell wie möglich aufhört weil er
danach politisch erledigt sein wird er
hat überhaupt keine Glaubwürdigkeit mehr
Herr Lanz er müsste weg ich weiß nicht
wie sowas geht da müssten die ich war
jetzt in Israel diesem Jahr ich habe mit
den Leuten gesprochen die gegen die die
Verhunzung der Verfassung demonstriert
haben also gegen die Aufhebung
rechtsstaatlicher Regeln und das waren
ja Millionen auf der Straße das ist auch
Israel und da gibt es eine Opposition da
gibt's liberale gibt's Sozialdemokraten
warikale ja aber im Grunde ist das jetzt
eine eine ganz unglückselige Situation
dass dieser Mann verantwortlich ist
jetzt für die Kriegsführung und wo ist
eigentlich was ist sein politisches Ziel
was will er denn erreichen ja er hat er
hat nichts dazu beigetragen oder sehr
wenig dass es zu einem Ausgleich
gekommen ist mit den palästinens ist
sehr schwierig wahrscheinlich ist die
Gelegenheit lange verpatzt worden und
und die Siedlungspolitik nicht ist ja
auch
angreifbar er hat die Rechten
Radikalinskis sozusagen in seine
Regierung genommen und die haben
aggressiv in in
westjordland gewirkt genau ist
auch noch mal ganz anderes Thema und ich
find es gut dass sie sehr sauber auch
differenzieren und sagen Hass und Hetze
gegen Juden ist etwas anderes als
israelische Politik zu ja natürlich ja
und dar legitim auch auf deutchen
Straßen legitim absolut trotzdem noch
mal die Frage an Sie wobei vielleicht
noch eine eine Zwischenfrage Herr Baum
ich habe dieser Tage darüber nachgedacht
putin ist über 70 Netanyahu ist 75 und
dann gibt's noch ein paar andere auch in
theran und anderswo ist es nicht
wahnsinn was was alte Männer gerade so
auf der Welt anrichten ja und
möglicherweise wieder anrichten denken
Sie an Trump ja richtig ich habe gestern
ein ganz unruhigen Tag verbracht als
gelesen habe er hatte den Umfragen den
beiden überholt ne wäre ja entsetzlich
auch ein alter Mann nein ich habe das
Gefühl dass die Jugend der Welt
unfassbar die Nase voll hat von diesen
alten Männern die sie immer wieder in
neue Konflikte neue Kriege und neues
Unglück führen aber was ist da passiert
dass z.B an einem amerikanischen
Universitäten die Studentenschaft
gespalten ist ein Teil äh ist also auch
durchus mit einem gewissen Verständnis
unterwegs für die Aggression wie
erklären Sie sich das das ist ja sehr
interessant in diesen Tagen auch viel
besprochen der Judenhass von links und
was auch hier in der Sendung immer
wieder auch beklagt wird ist auch in
diesem Land dieses dröhnende schweigen
von links von vielen Aktivisten die sich
nicht klar positionieren ja das halte
ich für ganz gefährlich es geht ja um
mehr wir haben das ja eben schon erwähnt
es geht um die Zukunft unserer
Demokratie nicht sie ist nicht
unmittelbar gefährdet aber wenn es so
weitergeht dann müssten eigentlich die
die schweend da sitzen und glauben die
das Grundgesetz sei ihnen in den Schoß
gefallen endlich sich sich melden das
tun jetzt Gott sei Dank einige
Schriftsteller habe ich gelesen es gibt
eine ganze Liste da ist der D grünband
dabei und viele andere die die gesagt
haben wir müssen jetzt unsere Stimme
erheben nicht nur gegen Antis
für diese Verfassung die muss gelebt
werden
und die gleichgültigen sind gefährlich
die die jenigen die die Verfassung
angreifen sind gefährlich und ich habe
manchmal das Gefühl wo ist eigentlich
die politische Bildung geblieben es gibt
junge Leute die die fordern wir auf die
Verfasser zu verteidigen und sie wissen
gar nicht was das ist ich will das nicht
ver allgemeinern aber ich ich würde mich
z.B freuen wenn die FDP
eine als Freiheitspartei eine Bewegung
in Gang setzte verteidigen wir unsere
Demokratie gegen alle Gefährdung und der
Antisemitismus ist eine elementare die
FDP sind manchen Umfragen bei 4% ja was
istüber dazu konnte ich eine Menge sagen
al fät jetzt aus dem Rahmen ne fät es
nicht zurecht ist sie zurecht dort bei
diesen 4% es reicht nicht was sie macht
versteht sie sie hat sie macht sie macht
in der Ampel hat sie ihre ihre Position
da ist vieles in Ordnung und aber sie
sie muss darauf achten dass die Ampel
insgesamt funktioniert dass wir das
Gefühl haben wir werden gut
regiert und sie muss dem Liberalismus
Atem verleihen ein Lebensgefühl zum
Ausdruck bringen in diesen Umbrüchen
sagen was bedeutet
Freiheit in einer Situation wo wir die
Zukunft neu denken müssen erklärt das
jemand gerade gibt es Menschen die das
wirklich erklären an der Spitze dieses
Landes ich zögere mit der Antwort ich
merk's ja wir müssen den Menschen so
vieles erklären und es ist warum tun wir
das nicht her warum ich weiß es nicht da
gibt's eine Angst vor der Wahrheit sagen
wir doch den Menschen die Wahrheit geht
nicht so es geht nicht so weiter es geht
aus vielen Gründen nicht so weiter und
man man nicht mehr gewäht werden Herr
Baum sie könnten das erklären was
passiert eigentlich gerade ich meine ich
habe neulich juvalur harari zugehört der
ja ich Geschichtsprofessor aus Jerusalem
wahnsinnig interessanter Denker und
Autor der sagt es geht hier jetzt etwas
zu Ende in der Geschichte der Menschheit
die friedlichste Phase überhaupt in der
Geschichte der Menschheit könnte sein
und er wei darauf hin und sagt vor 10
Jahren waren die Kriege die Konflikte
weltweit auf einem Tiefstand ja es gab
kaum Länder die andere über fallen haben
die die versucht haben andere Länder zu
vernichten und so weiter das ist vorbei
ja die Pandemien sind zurück das heißt
er er sagt wir müssen wirklich dringend
unseren Kurs ändern und weil dritter
Punkt wir auch dabei sind das zu
verlieren was man die demokratische
Mitte nennt ja wir werden das ist auch
ein neues Element das Internet wir
werden von Hass überflutet im Internet
allein jetzt diese diese Meldungen
Falschmeldung über den anaos Konflikt
Tausende in wenigen Tagen 30 usende wer
wer wer nimmt das wahr und es ist
wirklich so dass wir
eine Phase die wir mit großem Optimismus
gesehen haben nach dem Kriege nämlich
dem Optimismus die welmenschheit ist zur
Besinnung gekommen nehmen Sie die
Allgemeine Erklärung der Menschenrechte
wird jetzt am 10 Dezember 75 Jahre alt
da steht da ist steht
drin wir schreiben diese allgemeine
Erklärung wir das waren alle Religionen
alle Weltkulturen weil wir sehen dass
das Gewissen der Menschheit durch die
Barbarei zutiefst verletzt war und dann
kam die Karter der Vereinten Nationen
hat gesagt Friedens ohne Menschenwürde
geht nicht und die Grollen des Krieges
muss beseitigt werden und es gibt
keineut die Kriege führen kann es sei
denn Selbstverteidigung also das war
eine eine Phase der
besondnenheit und dass das nicht immer
gehalten hat das wissen wir aber es war
ein Maßstab und ich fürchte dieser
Maßstab geht wenn man nicht wirklich
jetzt dringend etwas tun geht zu Bruch
wie kommt das wie kommt das dass Leute
plötzlich diese Demokratie diese
liberale Art zu Leben plötzlich nicht
mehr wirklich zu schätzen wissen zeigt
sich da sozusagen auch eine Schwäche
unseres Systems insofern als wenn sie
wenn sie Putin sind und jemand muckt auf
dann packen Sie den in in Knast und nie
wieder raus navalni ist das Stichwort
sie kennen den Mann haben haben sie
immer noch Kontakt zu ihm also jetzt ist
auch in meinem Straflager also ist große
Mühe dass ein Anwalt überhaupt Z kommt
aber vorher war das Habers sie sie
hatten immer wieder Kontakt mit ihm
deswegen habe ich das vorhin auch gesagt
sie sind jemand der weltweit sehr se
respektiert wird für den Kampf um
Menschenrechte der als Anwalt als
Vermittler auch immer wieder
eingeschaltet wird das nötigt mir sehr
sehr großen Respekt ab weil ich frage
mich dennoch zeigt sich da eine Schwäche
unseres Systems wenn sie chiing Ping
sind und sie haben ein Problem mit
Uiguren dann Buchten sie die Leute
einfach ein dann sperren sie die einen
Konzentrationslager und haben offiziell
sozusagen Ruhe wenn sie Putin sind
sperren sie na walne ins wenn Sie ein
autoritärer Anführer irgendwo in in
Afrika sind machen sie genau das gleich
äh wenn Sie eine Demokratie sind dann
müssen Sie die Meinung des anderen
ertragen und nicht nur das wenn sie ein
echter Demokrat sind dann würden sie
jederzeit alles dafür tun um selbst eine
Meinung die ihnen nicht passt zu
verteidigen ja weil sie sagen das muss
sein das ist in Ordnung so aber in dem
Moment wo sie diese beiden Meinungen so
verteidigen müssen kommen sie zu dem
Problem Stichwort essen dann sehen sie
plötzlich die Polizei vor Islamisten in
Essen stehen und sie spüren diese
Hilflosigkeit weil da sehen sie Fahnen
die so aussehen als würden sie zum is
gehören aber sie sind nicht wirklich is
fahen dann steht da irgendeine Suche aus
dem Koran drauf dann kann man immer
sagen Freunde was wollt ihr eigentlich
wir haben hier lediglich an Wort unseres
Propheten drauf das sind Bilder von von
vergangener Woche in in ess und sie
spüren diese Hilflosigkeit diese
Ohnmacht eines Staates und dann sitzt
hier wieder jemand in der Sendung und
sagt da muss jetzt die ganze Härte des
Gesetzes W danch fragt und sagt was ist
denn die Härte des Gesetzes dann merkt
man ganz schnell es ist Demokratie ein
großer Teil dessen was sie da sehen
sogar das ja ist mit Meinungsfreiheit
begründet schlicht untergreifen und dann
sehen sie ein letztes Beispiel noch nur
ein Satz noch ich habe mitgekriegt in
Frankreich wurde jetzt eine junge Frau
zu 5 Monaten Haft 5 Monate
Knast verknackt weil sie auf eine Kipper
gespuckt hat ja das ist sehr drastisch
aber es ist der eine Fall der mir so
bekannt ist und ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob sich das auf Dauer so durchhalten
lässt das heißt kommen wir da an Grenzen
einer einer Demokratie und steht
deswegen unser ganzes System so auf dem
Spiel weil es so angreifbar ist also sie
haben von Ohnmacht gesprochen ja ich
will das mal auf die Spitze treiben
jetzt die Ohnmacht ist auch unsere
Stärke das stimmt nicht also wir wir wir
haben eine Demokratie in der vieles
möglich ist äh sie können sie können
Meinung äußern bis bis zum Äußersten sie
können auch demonstrieren soweit soweit
sie bestimmte Regeln ja so nach nach dem
Motto ich bin nicht deiner Meinung aber
ich würde alles dafür tun dass du sie
jederzeit sagen darf also wir haben
bewusst eine Demokratie aufgebaut aber
nicht so dass wir diese
Freiheit
preisgeben für die Leute die die
Demokratie abschaffen wollen hat der
Karl Schmidt mal am Ende der Beratung
zund Gesetz gesagt ihr müsst aufpassen
dass nicht die dran kommt die unsere
neue Freiheit des Grundgesetz
missbrauchen um es abzuschaffen das hat
ja Göbbels gesagt da ist der 1930 in den
Reichstag gewählt Word sagt jetzt werden
wir mit euren parlamentarischen Mitteln
euch vernichten denn das der
Punkt glaube wir sollten diese
Stärke die wir sind ein freier Staat das
ist der Rei ja wir sollten das nicht in
Zweifel ziehen aber umso mehr müssen wir
müssen wir dafür sorgen dass das den
Menschen bewusst wird und dass sie sehen
was passieren kann wenn wir es nicht tun
sie sagen selber Herr Baum es gibt da
gerade eine ernstzunehmende
Vertrauenskrise zwischen Regierenden und
regierten ja und und wenn sie sagen wir
müssen aufpassen dass uns das nicht
ernsthaft verrutscht die Frage woher
kommt das und was was ist dagegen zu tun
also einmal muss man sagen die die
Situation ist wahnsinig Komplex also wer
wer konnte das voraushheben als die
Koalitionsvereinbarung geschrieben wurde
was da alles noch passiert dann ist drei
Parteien jetzt
bundesampel die die zum Teil weit
auseinander sind ihren Grund Gefühl
grundausansichten die müssen sich
zusammenrauen keine Entschuldigung in
dieser Situation haben die Menschen
Anspruch aufgeklärt zu werden dass sie
die Dinge erklärt werden dass sie ihn
möglicherweise die Politiker auch sagen
wir wissen selber nicht genau wie das
weitergeht wir bemühen uns also auch
Schwächen zeigen und nicht immer alles
versprechen ja sondern auch sagen es ist
es ist nicht alles Beispiel Beispiel
Migration ja da können sie natürlich
sagen alle müssen raus die nicht hier
auf Status haben rechtlich ja aber es
ist wahnsinnig schwer das zu machen ja
also also sie sie sagen sie vermissen
den Innenpolitiker der sich hinstellt
und sagt pass auf wir können uns das
alles wünschen wir können auch rechtlich
alles begründen aber die Wahrheit die
ihr alle nicht hören wollt ist wer hier
ist ich hab dieser Tag eine Zahl gelesen
99% derer die es irgendwie in die EU
schaffen bleiben ja das ist das ist
jetzt in dieser Situation schwierig zu
vermitteln ist ist auch nicht Wahrheit
ganzig ist es die Wahrheit ist dass das
eben sehr sehr schwer ist dann würde ich
sagen wir bemühen uns nach besten
Kräften ja das will keiner mehr hören
das ja das will keiner mehr hören und
dann wähen sie eben AFD wobei ich der
Meinung bin die Motivation AFD zu wählen
beruht nicht nur auf den ungelösten
Migrationsproblem also nach die
Vorstellung wir lösen das alles und der
Spuk ist i ist absolut falsch absolut
falsch worauf beruht das noch was würden
Sie sagen es ist eine eine Strömung im
Gange der
systemverachtung ja also auch der der
Regeln nach denen wir leben also der
Meinungsfreiheit nicht also das das
sagen uns diejenigen die es gibt eine
neue Studie der ebstiftung
z.B erschreckend wie viel Leute Manifest
rechtsextremistisch sind nicht und
das heißt sie leben das was wir
aufgebaut haben nach dem Krieg wir haben
doch einigeegückte Demokratie aufgebaut
ich will jetzt nicht alles im Grund und
Boden reden nicht wir haben ein
globliches Potenzial auch Krisen zu
bewältigen was wir aufgebaut haben
müssen wir bewahren und dazu gehört
Europa ich frage mich ja was haben diese
Leute eigentlich vor die Europa wieder
zurückentwickeln wollen in Richtung auf
Nationalstaat haben sie vergessen dass
unter grrundgesetz im in der Präambel
die die Verpflichtung der deutschen
enthält in einem vereinten Europa dem
Frieden der Welt zu dienen das ist das
ist ein Lebenselement es gibt auf der
ganzen Welt keine 27 Staaten mit dem
freigewählten
Parlament ja ich ich ich überlege gerade
haben die vergessen was wir eigentlich
erlebt haben ich meine die EU also oder
Vorläufer Organisationen auch wurde
gegründet von den Verlierern des Zweiten
Weltkriegs
ja ja wenn sie nach Osteuropa schauen
ist eine völlig andere Situation ja ja
es hat eine andere Geschichte eine ganz
ganz andere Geschichte und wenn man sich
das kommt sozusagen aus dem aus dem aus
dem nationalstaatsgedanken heraus eine
völlig andere Geschichte diese
Demütigung an dem Punkt die Lehre daraus
das Erschrecken darüber was man selber
angerichtet hat äh das gab's da so nicht
ja und ich ich frage mich da manchmal ob
wir ähm jemand in der Lage sein werden
das zusammenzuführen diese die diese
diese mentalitätten wenn man so will
auch
zusammenzuführen und ich würde sie gerne
Fragen Herr Baum als jemand der ein sehr
sehr guter Jurist ist der Innenminister
war macht ih das Angst wenn Sie darüber
nachdenken wie leicht es eigentlich geht
ein System wie unseres von innen heraus
anzugreifen wenn man sich das mal
anschaut in in Ungarn z.B auch in Polen
da kommt ja keiner sagt guten Tag ich
bin der
Autoritarismus und jetzt errichten wir
hier eine eine was auch immer für eine
Staatsstruktur und wir übernehmen die
Macht und wir oder in Israel z.B
netanahu das war ja nicht wir versuchen
jetzt einen Staatsstreich als sondern
das geht so Salami taktikmäßig deswegen
waren dann auch so viele Menschen auf
der Straße und gesagt nee ne nee ne nee
wir mehr spüren was ihr da gerade
vorhabt aber in Ungarn z.B das sind
gewiefte Juristen konservative im
Machtrausch die an die Macht gekommen
sind oder die Kinskis auch in Polen und
dann dreht man an so ein paar Hebel ja
und sagt z.B ihr sagt doch immer die
Justiz ist überlastet hier haben wir
neue Richterstellen für euch besetzen
wir dann aber mit unseren Leuten oder
wir setzen die Altersgrenze nach unten
und schicken alle die uns nicht passen
damit automatisch in die Rente hat Trump
hat es in Amerika die Republikaner haben
es genauso gemacht das heißt das ist
ganz leicht angreifbar ich zieh es mal
auf Deutschland Thüringen da kommt jetzt
bürn höcke als großer Wahlsieger raus ja
jetzt nur mal das Unmögliche gedacht ja
der Mann wird jetzt Ministerpräsident
führt eine Koalition an und sagt dann
okay als erstes schaffen wir mal oder
kündigen wir den medienstaatsvertrag ja
oder und machen und machen einen
senderfreies Thüringen was auch immer ja
wie das geht was da alles möglich ist
das ist irgendwo in den Untiefen der
thüringischen Verfassung sozusagen drin
damit hat sich nie einer wirklich
beschäftigt aber verfassungsrechter
sagen das geht kann man machen was dann
es gibt eine gewisses Quorum
beispielsweise bei der Benennung von
Richtern zu
Bundesverfassungsgericht dass dass jede
Entscheidung blockieren kann also ich
könnte mir in Thüringen z.B vorstellen
die schaffen das das Gesetz über den
Verfassungsschutz ab ne W sie nicht mehr
beobachtet z nicht also die man und Herr
L es ist ja schon jetzt eine Situation
dass sie in den allen Parlamenten sitzen
Kommunalparlamenten auch wenn ihre
Anträge nicht durchgehen haben sie einen
gewissen Einfluss auf das
Klima die Meinungsbildung denken Sie mal
an die Kunstfreiheit oder an die die
Rundfunkfreiheit das Sagen konservative
demokratische
cdupitiker die Berichterstattung des
öffentlichen grundfuns unausgewogen das
sagt die AFD die nicht die AFD ja aber
ja aber das ist das da da ist schon die
Anpassung im Gange nicht also das heißt
der Satz von gauland der berüchtigte
Satz wie werden sie jagen er nenen sie
sich an V paar Jahren natlich ist der
ist der Realität geworden na so haben
wir uns nicht jagen lassen aber wir sind
nicht widerstandsfähig genug es gibt
eine
Verführung von der sie eben gesprochen
haben eine
verführungsmöglichkeit zur Unfreiheit ja
es gibt Menschen die sich verführen
lassen und die wählen die Ihnen Schaden
nicht also gar nicht bewusst sind was
sie anrichten nicht wir der schad Trump
schadet Amerika und der ganzen Welt und
trotzdem war
Anhänger also die Verführung zur
Unfreiheit ist ist im Grunde müssen wir
immer geschichtsbewusst äh überlegen wo
kommen wir her wir kommen aus der
Aufklärung wir kommen von der großen
Bewegung im 18 Jahrhundert Französische
Revolution die amerikanische
Unabhängigkeitserklärung wir da wir
kommen von Kant die Menschenwürde jedes
einzelnen Menschen und die wird ja
bestritten im Antisemitismus wird den
Juden diese Menschen würde
abgesprochen